[Musique]
je suis ravi de vous retrouver avec
Pascal Quignard bonjour Pascal c'est
donc les heures heureuses chez Albin
Michel le voici le voilà j'ai l'énorme
défaut d'écrire sur les couvertures des
livres mais ça prouve que je les aime et
c'est pour ça d'Illes que nous sommes là
au bonheur des livres c'est pour vous
donner envie de découvrir donc les deux
auteurs que nous avons sélectionnés
aujourd'hui Dominique Barbery une façon
d'aimer chez galimar vous venez
d'obtenir ma chère Dominique Le Grand
Prix de l'Académie française donc je
vous félicite au nom des téléspectateurs
de Public Sénat on sait que Pascal a
obtenu à peu près toutes les récompenses
littéraires qui peuvent exister en
France le goncour le prix de l'Académie
française aussi donc et en plus c'est un
grand avantage de vous recevoir tous les
deux c'est que vous vous appréciez ce
qui n'est pas toujours le cas dans le
domaine de la littérature je vais
commencer avec vous Dominique une façon
d'aimer c'est publié chez galimar c'est
un roman donc dont vous dites que c'est
une fiction
absolue mais qui se passe dans des
endroit que vous connaissez bien
puisqu'il s'agit de Nantes et qu'il
s'agit aussi de Douala au Cameroun euh
j'ai eu l'impression au début du roman
qu'il s'agissait d'une sorte de non pas
de parapluie de cherbo mais de parapluie
de N une jeune femme plutôt
discrète très jolie comme l'était un peu
Catherine deu dans Les Parapluies de
Cherbourg mais plutôt version Michel
Morgan c'est ce que lui dit l'homme qui
essaie de la séduire donc au Cameroun
elle a C cette adolescence qui sort de
la guerre ou un peu triste un peu triste
mais en même temps où des choses sont
très importantes les chansons
Dior la façon de s'habill oui le New ou
oui parce que je pense que pendant la
guerre il y avait beaucoup de privations
en plus elle vient d'un milieu modeste
elle s'appelle Madeleine elle s'appelle
Madeleine elle d'infirmière ouais
c'était un prénom de l'époque et puis
euh ça fait aussi référence à la chanson
de de brê est cité dans dans le roman
oui euh et puis euh il y a une espèce de
bonheur de s'habiller que les femmes
redécouvre avec cette mode neuve ces
robes élégantes pour lesquelles j'ai
beaucoup de goûtes entr à mais ça a été
la réalité de laa près-guerre parce que
c'est pas du tout une chose inventée
c'est à la fois votre talent mais en
même temps ça a été la réalité toutes
les femmes de la près guerre ah oui oui
oui et moi quand j'étais enfant je
regardais avec bonheur les publicités
puisque c'était quand même la mode qui
qui était
encore actuel pendant mon enfance donc
oui Madeleine elle a ce ce côtélà mais
alors c'est vrai que la région nantaise
je la connais bien je connais moins
l'Afrique tout de même en tout cas je
connais moins d'Ila puisque je n'ai fait
qu' naître j'y suis né juste avant
l'indépendance et mais j'en ai beaucoup
entendu parler à travers les récites mes
parents qui avaient vécu là-bas puisque
c'est vrai que la la chronologie du
roman suit un peu le parcours de mes
parents qui sont partis là-bas dans les
années 50 et j'ai au moment de la
décolonisation il faut être clair donc
après exactement après le discours du
général de gale à Brazaville et en même
temps que celui qui l'a prononcé à Dakar
donc c'est le moment où ça va
ouais et ça voilàou j'en perd le livre
oui Madeleine arrive en 55 c'està-dire
au moment où les tensions s'exacerbent
parce que
l'UPC l'Union des populations du
Cameroun qui était le parti
indépendantiste est passé à la
clandestinité il y a une répression
ouais alors elle a épousé un homme qui
s'appelle Guy ce qui est très poétique
dans le livre c'est qu'à un moment par
exemple quand il se rencontre est qui
d'ailleurs une énigme parce que votre
livre il est à la fois atmosphérique et
énigme
je m'explique il est atmosphérique parce
qu'on découvre ce climat de l'aprèerre
puis après on découvre le climat de ce
qu'on appelait les colonie avec la
décolonisation qui arrive mais en même
temps il y a une énigme parce que c'est
un peu
l'anti comment dirais-je l'anti héroïne
de de Duras Madeleine c'est que elle est
comment peut-on dire d'une discrétion et
elle a un rapport avec les hommes qui
est très particulier oui elle elle reste
à distance euh euh on ne sait pas très
bien ce qu'elle cherche d'ailleurs on ne
sait pas très bien ce qu'elle est et
l'enquête que fait la narratrice puisque
c'est la sa nièce en fait qui après la
mort de Madeleine va essayer de
reconstituer ce qui était sa vie euh se
heurte au fond à toutes sortes de
silence en fait c'est un roman sur le le
silence d'une femme quand elle se marie
même sa mère hein au fond on va tourner
autour de ça même même sa mère au moment
où elle se marie elle est un peu peu
sidéré de ce mariage d' lui des conseils
d'Urs d'pousé oui parce que la mère au
fond est assez féministe et puis elle
voit bien que sa fille n'a pas l'air
entraîné par une espèce de de bonheur
fou il d'ailleurs une promenade
pardonnez-moi parce qu'il faut souvent
revenir au libre dans dans l'arrière
panté il essaie de la convaincre au fond
de florter Soyons simple pour reprendre
un peu le vocabulaire de l'époque et
elle se met totalement en recul et en
même temps elle accepte de l'épouser
alors que ses parents sont un peu
stomaqué ouais sous l'effet d'une espèce
de décision et c'est vrai que on ne peut
pas savoir si c'est qu'elle se résout à
un schéma sommes toutes classiquees hein
parce qu'elle se marie un peu tard à 26
ans elle a coiffé sainte- Catherine
comme on disait à l'époque alors est-ce
que c'est ça on ne sait pas très bien
est-ce que tout à coup cet homme lui lui
inspire
confiance oui dites-vous dans le livre
oui il est rassurant il est rassurant
ouais alors c'est un homme qui part euh
vous allez découvrir aimer une façon
d'aimer alors la vie n'est pas facile à
Douala la vie n'est pas facile au
Cameroun mais en même temps ce sont des
gens qui s'exporte parce qu'ils y
gagnent de l'argent et ça leur permet
d'acheter des biens de consommation dont
on rêve dans l'après-guerre on y revient
c'est-à-dire il s'achètent une qu
chevaux il achète des euh des appareils
photos codac dont on rêvait à l'époque
et puis il y a toute une chose que j'ai
beaucoup aimé et qui va toucher aussi
euh Pascal Quignard c'est le rapport non
pas à la littérature mais à la chanson
comme manière d'évoer qui le passé et là
il y a dès le début du livre une chanson
absolument magnifique de gu Béard qui
s'appelle le bal chez temporel et bien
que nous soyons une émission de
littérature et donc absolument
littérature voici gubéard un jour ou
l'autre pense à ceux qui tous ont laissé
leur nom
gravé auprès d'une
are d'une rencontre au bord de
ne reste que quatre
initiales et de cœurs taillés au couteau
dans le bois des tables
bancal voilà pour gbert le bal temporel
c'est évidemment une chanson absolument
magnifique à une période d'ailleurs où
il y a encore une forme de résistance à
l'égard de tout ce qui va déferler
évidemment sur la France et sur l'Europe
à savoir le rock la musique anglosaxone
vous en parlez d'ailleurs on est dans la
période juste avant et alors puisque
j'ai failli vous inviter à danser mais
je me suis retenu il faut savoir que
donc avec ce Guy à
Douala à force de rencontre dans le
petit milieu de la délégation où au fond
tout le monde bruiss de relation
sexuelles
d'avancement se présente une sorte
d'aventurier dont on ne sait pas très
bien s'il travaille pour les services
secrets pour les gens général de Go qui
s'appelle y y prig et qui est très
attiré par cette Madeleine qui est tout
en retenue et elle l'invite à danser
elle dit non moi je ne danse jamais et
puis finalement h c'est le romanesque
tout à coup qui qui s'abat sur la vie de
cette femme discrète puisqu'elle est au
bord de la piste et au fond elle est au
bord de la piste comme elle a l'air
d'être au bord de la vie et cet homme
s'avance oui c'est le schéma romanesque
euh c'est le bal c'est voilà la
rencontre il faut bien entendre oui
exactement parce que la chanson de Guy
Béard est liée profondément au livre
puisqu'elle évoque un amour dont on va
évoquer le souvenir hein et dont il ne
reste pas grand-chose c'est c'est un peu
un roman sur les traces aussi d'un d'un
amour c'est un roman qui pose la
question qu'est-ce qui reste de quelque
chose qui a à peine été vécu mais qui
reste comme un éblouissement une
génération de chanteurs français ran Léo
feré avec le temps et cetera qui sont
très axés justement sur cette version
j'allais presque dire proustienne de la
chanson qui parle du temps puis elle
parle de l'amour et c'est un roman dans
lequel au fond Madeleine est silencieuse
Madeleine ne dira jamais euh ce qu'elle
ressent et au fond c'est à travers les
chanson que passe l'essentiel de ce
climat amoureux je crois aussi que les
chansons comme un peu les les phrases
toutes faites comme les lieux communs
c'est au fond la manière dont on a
arrive à peu près à parler du monde et
euh au
fond je pense qu'on ne dit rien
d'important on n'arrive pas à dire ce
qu'on ressent et Madeleine peut-être
elle se tait parce que ce qu'elle
ressent elle n'arrive pas à le dire en
tout cas moi si j'écris aussi j'ai
l'impression que c'est parce que c'est
la seule manière d'arriver à dire ce que
je ressens et alors après évidemment
cette tension
amoureuse vous fait basculer de vers
quelque chose que vous avez déjà traité
sur le plan styistique c'est fa quelque
chose qui est un peu je dis pas qu'on
est dans le polar mais on se demande
quand même ce qui va se passer parce
qu'il se donne rendez-vous plusieurs
fois dans doila à un moment il va monter
dans un avion pour aller à Yaoundé et il
va disparaître ettive prigan dans
l'avion mais vous dites tout non je ne
dis pas tout je sais pas ce qui va se
passer il va disparaître ne fait que
disparaître donc et c'est là où
justement ce roman est
et est incroyablement agréable à lire
c'est que vous basculez justement de de
de j'allais dire de l'atmosphérique au
suspense quoi d'une certain manière à la
fois amoureux et en même temps presque
comme une enquête oui oui et le fait de
de placer ça en Afrique indépendamment
du fait que je je tenais à parler de de
ce pays-là de cette époque là à laquelle
j'ai j'ai beaucoup rêvé j'entendais
notamment chez mes parents des des
récits comme ça de ces accidents d'avion
et j'en ai placé un dans le roman dès
leur arrivée Guy avait donné à Madeleine
des renseignements sur les histoires des
uns et des autres ça c'est évidemment le
monde colonial tel qu'il existait à
l'époque à la fin des années 50 parce
qu'il faut parler justement de ce climat
qui existe autour de Douala vous dites à
propos justement de tous ces quartiers
qui sont nombreux qui s'appellent
Bonanjo Aqua où il y a un un super
moteur voilà Aqua Palace newbell et
cetera euh vous parlez de la nuit d'une
certaine manière euh donc ce personnage
est l'héroïne d'un roman qui n'a jamais
été écrit mais que vous allez écrire et
puis en même temps il y a quelque chose
de particulier autour de tes cathédrales
autour du cinéma euh et du climat je
terminerai simplement un moment dans une
lecture que vous citez dans le livre
page 99 l'obscurité totale ça vous donne
l'idée de ce que pouvait être Douala à
l'époque euh personne ne parle plus le
bruit des crissc on entend C là que le
CR menu de quelques carnacier nocturne
le vombissement subi d'un scarabé le
bois de la bellustrade alors je vais pas
dire et cetera et cetera parce que ce
serait une manière de banaliser
l'écriture de Dominique qui est une
écriture magnifique mais en tout cas ça
donne l'impression justement que ce
drame personnel cette vie qui continue
car cette femme rentrera à Nant et ne
dira jamais rien de ce qui s'est passé y
compris à sa fille Sophie même si
celle-ci se doute que se promener avec
un homme comme ça inconnu pas pu laisser
sa mère
voilà euh mais nous allons continuer
cette conversation avec Pascal car nous
navons pas fini avec la littérature qui
est votre grande passion Pascal les
heures heureuses bon euh euh votre
carrière est une carrière je le disais
tout à l'heure plétorique le mot est un
peu absurde le dernier tome des heures
heureuses donc c'est c'est le dernier
royaume alors ça se résume d'une
certaine manière par une il s'agit de de
s'intéresser donc maintenant aux heures
les heures heureuses mais les heures
quand même et c'est assez bien résumé
dans une balade que vous faites à iskia
qui est une î magnifique vous promenez
avec votre compagne au bord de l'eau et
c'est la définition parfaite de ce que
peutvent être à un moment de la journée
et et cette balade inouie justement qui
qui résume parfaitement le le profil du
livre ou en tout cas son intention oui
oui c'est une belle scène en effet et
qui qui qui m'me en en parlant lorsque
le crépuscule vient lorsqu'on part pour
aller dîner à l'automne le soleil se
plutôt on longe les les les les les
vagues la demi tombe et de ce fait on ne
voit il faut suivre le liseré des vagues
sur le sa pour pouvoir atteindre la
petite gargotte où on va on va manger
des des poissons
grillés et c'est là quelque chose qui
est comment dire
Télémac a il y a 3 millénaires était la
même chose quand il arrivait sur le bord
de la mer en songeant à son père disparu
il y a quelque chose d'éternel euh les
heures heureuses donc à moment vous
dites ceux qui nous quittent il faut les
laisser à l'état d'énigme parce que là
justement exactement ce voilà c'est pour
ça que j'ai parlé de ça et et vous
parlez dans le livre par exemple d'un
personnage qui est une femme remarquable
une romancière qui nous a quitté qui
s'appelle Emmanuel bernem justement
alors j'allais dire je ne sais pas très
bien pourquoi vous l'avez fait entrer
dans C réflexion sur les heures c'est
une amie très proche je vais vous dire
je vais vous dire elle était romancière
elle était romancière je elle a disparu
violemment très jeune j'en ai beaucoup
souffert et l'image qui a été donnée
d'elle après sa mort ne ressemblait pas
du tout à celle que j'avais connu j'ai
eu comment dire le besoin dans un livre
sur les heures de faire quelque chose
qui est de la revoir je l'ai revu
comment dire dans la maison qu'elle
avait sur sur l'île auoine euh à à 5h à
5h ou 6h du matin debout près de la
consultant d'abord la météorologie
ensuite l'horaire démarré HM h pour
savoir quelle été toute la journée que
nous allonss faire en marchant pour
aller se baigner une ou deux fois parce
qu'elle épuisait son angoisse dans les
bains dans les bains effiné voyez comm s
bon et je me suis dit avec tout ce que
nous vivons toute l'histoire terrible
que nous vivons dans nos sociétés il y a
là quelque chose qui est plus actuel que
l'actuel la météorologisque la tempête
ce soir la pleine lune toutes ces
choseslà sont aussi actuelles que les
que les effroyables guerres que nous
pouvons qui se répètent interminablement
il a là un conflit d'actualité d'où la
présence de de cette scène dans ce livre
je me rappelle une interview de Godar à
la fin de sa vie qui avait été fait par
un de mes confrères en Suisse donc
Godard l'homme compliqué et vous êtes un
peu un peu l'homme compliqué de la
littérature parce que quiignard n'est
pas le gentil communion que l'on croit
mais c'est une sorte de sale gosse qui a
voulu inventer une forme de littérature
complexe pour rompre avec les autres
comme dans une vie secrète l'un de vos
livres oui c'est possible qu' quelqu
quelque chose j'ai jamais supporté qu'on
me qu'on m'attribue une identité
particulière ou avoir un rôle ou avoir
un métier j'ai dimissionné beaucoup j'ai
il y a quelque chose en effet de d'assez
rétif d'assez rétif chez
moi sale gosse je ne sais
pas non furtif et rétif je préfère comme
les chats comme un chat solitaire un
solitaire comme un chat ouais mais
d'ailleurs vous dites à un moment ce qui
est formidable c'est ceux qui
débranchent les sonneries euh qui
arrêtent avec les téléphones qui les
réveillent le matin euh d'une certaine
manière qui ne porte pas de cravate
comme c'est le cas souvent on voit la
télévision avec des chandails échancrés
moi j'ai l'impression d'être un un
épouventable fonctionnaire non un
épouventable fonctionnaire à côté de
vous et puis en même temps euh puisqu'il
s'agit des heures et là on revient
vraiment au cœur du livre au départ vous
racontez une scène qui est assez drôle
de mon point de vue qui est un concert
d'un ennui total avec Napoléon I et son
épouse et puis vous enchaînez sur
Saint-Jean de la Croix donc il y a une
sorte de c'est presque du de la
littérature hyper moderne américaine où
on fait des des des cutup on racemble
les chos VO ouais fragmentation mais ça
tourne autour du du temps quand même de
la question du tempsour autour du temps
mais les fragments 7h le dîner Napoléon
3 7h30 coupr qui tombe et donc pourquoi
ces rapprochements justement avec des
périodes qui n'ont aucun rapport mais
dans la seule le seul lien c'est
justement les heures et écoutez je je
suis né et j'ai vécu toute mon enfance
dans une ville complètement en ruine qui
s'appelait le Havre ouais si bien que
les grands discours s'était effondré et
dieu sais qu'il le méritait ces grand
discours de s'effondrer je l'ai vécu
dans des décombres et des ruines et tout
ce que j'écrit à cette apparence que
j'ai connu enfant h et leura toujours
donc superposer les étages les les
sédimentations un petit peu en désordre
comme une falaise qui s'effondre et
notre temps a quelque chose aussi de la
falaise qui s'effondre ça voilà voilà ce
que je je cherche un tout petit peu à
faire euh il y a une des phrases que
vous avez déclaré une journaliste que
j'aime beaucoup vous dites moi j'ai
écris parce que c'est la seule manière
de s'exprimer en se taisant oui
oui ça veut dire quoi Pascal B ça veut
dire que j'aime énormément être seul que
je que je trouve très difficile de
parler comme nous nous le faisons
volontiers j'espère agréablement mais
très agréablement mais je préfère
tellement me replier être là ne pas
avoir à me montrer ne pas avoir être
caché un peu
comme le lecteur est quelqu'un qui se
qui sent coquille dans son fauteuil ou
dans son lit qui se qui se blottit et
qui est heureux comme ça h ça c'est la
définition de blanchau si on on descend
donc théoricien de la littérature on
descend au plus profond de soi ou alors
comme Salinger l'auteur américain on va
se caché c'est on écrit la trappe cœur
bestseller mondial et puis on disparaît
on disparaît vous avez vu cette
tentation de temps en temps oui B quand
j'ai démissionné des je c'était c'est
contre nature pour moi de me de et et
puis je vais vous dire quand même et ça
se VO avec les pogromes qui ont eu
actuellement les foules me me terrifient
je suis profondément insolitaire je
comprends bien mieux comment dire
Jacqueline Pascal s en allant à
PortRoyal leschamp que le fait de
quelqu'un d'ouvrir la porte pour pour
entrer dans une manifestation j'en suis
pas capable oui mais alors là vous êtes
encore dans le paradoxe si je puis me
permettre parce que non mais c'est c'est
ça fera réagir Dominique et après
ensemble on va parler de ce que vous
considérez comme être profond dans la
littérature que vous pratiquez l'un et
l'autre depuis des années avec bonheur
si vous dites on a quand même beaucoup
de mal d' échapper au tyran et au dieux
al là vous venez de nous dire ce qui se
passe actuellement et qui nous marque
tous bah c'est quand même un écran entre
la littérature et l'histoire et en même
temps vous dites on peut pas y échapper
donc euh comment fir ça et bien
précisément c'est ça un peu ce que je je
pense euh je me souviens d'une phrase
qu' queut répéter Robert Antel vous
voyez qui au sortir des camp a écrit un
très beau livre sur sur l'espèce humaine
et qui disait qu'une des seules choses
qui pouvait le réconforter dans les
camps les plus terribles comme il y en a
encore de nos jours dans les camp les
plus terribles c'était pas du tout les
avions américains qui n'arrivaient pas
ou les avions anglais qui ne lançaient
pas de tracte du tout sur les camp de la
mort c'était la rotation du temps et les
saisons c'était les seules choses
fidèles qui a un peu de ciel bleu au
printemps qui est de l'herbe qui pousse
alors que tout tout le la terre entière
les avait abandonné voyez il y a une
rotation du temps qui est meilleure que
l'histoire l'histoire est linéaire il y
a dans le temps qui tourne quelque chose
qui peut nous même une tempête à noir
Moutier dominé ça peut nous ça peut
nous nous faire monter un peu au ciel
c'est c'est vertical ou bah de toute
façon pour avoir lu donc depuis tous les
matins du monde une grande partie de
votre œuvre il y a toujours le sentiment
que la nature est la valeur suprême que
la musique puisque vous êtes
violoncaliste est aussi une des valeurs
suprême et que l'art donc puisque c'est
aussi la littérature de l'art ce sont
les valeurs suprêmes qui nous guident
bien plus que l'histoire et évidemment
tous ces événements qui nous poignardent
les heures heureuses c'est publié chez
Albin Michel je ne peux pas tout
raconter parce que ça n'a strictement
aucun intérêt de lire les livres à la
télévision il faut les lire tranquille
chez soi maintenant nous allons bavarder
ensemble car l'émission est loin d'être
terminée de littérature puisque
Dominique vous enseignez la littérature
la stylistique vous l'avez fait jusqu'à
a encore peu de temps à la Sorbonne à
science pour vous donner les ateliers
d'écriture et moi ce qui me passionne
aussi c'est que dans les générations
puisquon appartient à tous les trois à
peu près la même génération mais qui
nous ont juste suivi j'allais dire la
génération de Welbeck la génération de
Virginie despantes la génération de
Christine Ango ils sont passés à quelque
chose de très différent de ce que je
décrivais tout à l'heure vous concernant
disons d'atmosphérique par exemple
Modiano appartient un peu au même monde
que vous un monde où il y a des ombres
un monde où rien n'est totalement défini
eux ils mettent comment trop les pieds
dans le plat pas assez comment vous
définiriez ce qui s'est passé après vous
bah je sais pas c'est aussi une question
parce que vous l'enseignez oui oui c'est
vrai c'est moi j'ai essayé d'enseigner
ce que j'aimais aussi hein
euh Kens oui enfin moi je travaille sur
la littérature française quand même en
stylistique mais je suis aussi une
grande lectrice du roman anglais du
roman féminin anglais enfin bon j'adore
tekov euh
j'aiesséprs une question deér et puis
moi je suis une flobertienne c'està-dire
que j'ai lu
flauert et ça a été une révélation et
voilà c'est ma
boussole et ce que j'aime chez lui et
c'est au fond ce que j'essaie de faire
c'est c'est cette bon il y a un côté le
côté
bovarisant cas madele voilà je pense que
je l'ai je pense que la plupart de mes
personnages féminins ont ce côté
bauvarisant mais c'est pas seulement ça
qui m'intéressait chez Flaubert c'est
cette manière qu' a de nous amener comme
ça face au monde à cette espèce d'être
là du monde dont on n'arrive pas à
parler et quelquefois il nous amène
comme ça jusqu'à la crème qui tremble il
y a des il y a dans un cœur simple une
évocation de la mer où on voit les côtes
du Havre et la mer plate comme ça dans
un moment où ils sont tous là dans dans
une espèce de paix qui n'a rien à voir
avec l'histoire qui l'espèce de de
l'homme présent au monde et je trouve ça
tellement beau il y a des il y a des
choses tellement belles et je me suis
dit en lisant ça voilà moi c'est c'est
ça que je veux faire voulais vous
demander Pascal justement estce que ces
générations qui vous ont suivi même
parfois qui vous ont contesté quand vous
avez eu con courours avec SPR disent au
fond Quignard il est complexe il y a des
moments où iless essaie d'échapper avec
une certaine forme de préciosité au
grand public vous vous souvenez de cette
bataille je pense si elle vous a laissé
de bons souvenirs si vous en foutez
complètement mais cette génération
justement qui est celle bah des des des
Welbeck et des autres qui sont des
balsacien rock and roll quoi au fond
elle elle vous donne quelle impression
moi je pense qu'il y a toujours eu comme
comm comment dire c'est une alternance
entre quelque chose qui est très lyrique
et quelque chose qui est très sociolog
que il y a toujours eu dans not histoire
au 19e siècle aussi est arrivé en
effet oui mais y compris Flobert et oui
malarmé l'autre côté complètement de
l'autre côté de même comment dire
l'article ahurissant de violence et de
bêtises de prou contre malarmée contre
l'obscurité bon bref il y a toujours eu
ce ce ce bon moi je suis en effet du
côté malarmé et pas du tout du côté
naturalist naturaliste balsacien mais je
ne vois pas pourquoi il faudrait que je
fasse une hiérarchie dans les valeurs là
je là je ne je ne crois pas c'est ce qui
est un tout petit peu triste et ça se
voit d'ailleurs dans les dans nos
lecteurs c'est qu'on saute à chaque fois
une génération il y a une génération
comment dire qui c'est c'est un un
mouvement de balancier comme ça vous
aurez de nouveau des lyriques et des
riles que et des et des malarmés qui
vont ressurgir dans dans 15 ans c'est le
balancement de l'histoire de l'histoire
de la littérature voà alors dernière
question et après nous allons passer aux
recommandations de la rédaction euh du
bonheur des livres c'est vrai que vous
avez un accident de santé qui a
déclenché pas je pas pour rentrer dans
l'anecdotique mais qui a déclenché cette
partie de votre œuvre qui s'appelle donc
dernier royaume et donc le nouveau tome
c'est les heures heureuses normalement
vous allez en écrire 14 on en est au 12e
c'est ça euh c'est vraiment cette
affaire personnelle qui a déclenché
cette partie de votre uvre qui est tout
à fait particulière voilà c'est
appartenir à quelque chose de plus long
et de plus durable que moi voyez c'est
un peu donc quelque chose dont je
n'aurais pas la fin et me plonger sauf
que ça va s'arrêter oui mais parce que
je pensais pas vivre aussi vieux C à
l'époque oui mais à l'époque j'étais je
crachais le sang je ne pouvais pas
savoir que ça durerait aussi longtemps
en tout cas merci à tous les deux
d'avoir accompagné donc au bonheur des
livres nous sommes ravis donc de
recommander les heures heureuses chez
Albin Michel et une façon d'aimer donc
de Dominique Barberis qui vient obtenir
le Grand Prix de l'Académie française
chez galimar ce qui prouve d'ailleurs
que là aussi il change le balancement là
dernière il s'agissait donc du mage du
cremelin qui est le grand prix de
l'Académie française qui était un livre
justement sur l'actualité et là nous
sommes dans un registre qui est
totalement différent je partage avec
vous euh donc les livres que nous
recommandons pour terminer vous
connaissez probablement cette collection
qui s'appelle ma nu au musée chez Stock
là c'est Jean-Luc cotalem qui a écrit
une chambre à l'hôtel mcong Le musée
Guimet donc il y a passé des heures et
des heures et voici ce texte c'est une
série qui a connu énorme énormément donc
de succès et c'est une très bonne idée
que de passer nuisée d'ailleurs
volontiers je me prêterai à l'exercice
nous sommes chez Grasset maintenant avec
non pas l'ensemble des œuvres de cocto
mais une grande partie des œuvres de
coctto CL d'Arnaud récemment a écrit
chez griné un essai formidable sur les
relations entre cocto et Picasso qui
était des relations extrêmement
difficiles on redécouvre
cocto à la fois l'homme qui écrit
l'homme qui dessine l'homme qui a voulu
peindre et qui a voulu parfois
concurrencer Picasso sans y arriver mais
l'œuvre est passionnante Nathalie saintc
l'ombre d'un traître c'est un roman qui
vient de sortir donc qui est publié chez
l'Observatoire alors c'est tout à fait
particulier c'est un jeune journaliste
nous sommes en 1960 et donc on rend
hommage au montvalérien à des héros de
la Résistance sauf que parmi les
cercueils qui sont là c'est le charme du
livre de Nathalie il y a un traître et
donc ce journal journaliste essaie de
débusquer quel est celui parmi ces ces
soi-disant héros de la Résistance qui
est le traître il aura les pires allez
je vais dire le mot je veux pas dire
ennui il aura les pierres emmerdement et
puis un monstre de la littérature chez
Dargo qui fait l'objet donc d'une BD il
sont mis à quatre l'Oustal Boquet
frental et évidemment simnon simnon
l'ostrogo c'est donc publié chez Dargo
les romans durs de simnon il faut les
lire et les relire parle pas simplement
des migr maigr il y en a eu une
cinquantaine sur les 150 romans qui a
écrit simnon à peu près euh c'est un
personnage inoui euh qui a écrit écrit
écrit écrit toute sa vie à qui nous
rendons hommage j'ai ravie de passer
cette demi-heure avec vous n'oubliez pas
je sais que vous allez à la foire de
Brive et c'est important de rencontrer
les lecteurs pour vous Dominique ah B
oui euh parce que qu'il vous lise c'est
important mais d'aller les voir de bah
c'est un un bonheur quand ils parlent
ils sont surtout tout depuis que j'ai eu
le prix ils viennent spontanément vous
féliciter des inconnus avec beaucoup de
de chaleur et je trouve que oui c'est
c'est vraiment un bonheur fort de Brive
nous la paraons un public cénénal nous
en sommes ravis évidemment c'est la
foire littéraire la plus importante avec
évidemment le Salon du Livre à Paris
merci 1000 fois Pascal d'être venu nous
voir nous allons partager avec vous ces
heures heureuses et merci de nous
permettre de faire ce voyage entre
Nantes et le Cameroun c'était au bonheur
des livres se retrouve évidemment la
semaine prochaine avec bonheur et
j'espère que vous allez passer la
meilleure nuit possible malgré
évidemment les temps qui sont les temps
agités mais il y a une antidote à ça
formidable ça s'appelle la
[Musique]
littérature